bonjour la voie est libre en direct tous
les samedis sur france 3 avec
aujourd'hui quatre voies pour débattre
du sujet de la semaine
la réforme du collège avec une grande
journée d'action syndicale mardi une
accélération du gouvernement qui a
publié les décrets mercredi mais encore
beaucoup de questions que nous allons
poser aux représentants du ps en
saône-et-loire stéphane duguay bonjour
vous soutenez la réforme au maire ump de
châlons sur saône gilles platret bonjour
bonjour vous vous opposez vous cette
réforme est à deux responsables
syndicaux jan chan divers secrétaire
académique du se-unsa pour la réforme
bonjour et il avait le cheviller pour le
snes fsu syndicat majoritaire
opposés à cette réforme bonjour il
affectionnait nos jours et j'ai vous
comme d'habitude vous pouvez réagir sur
les réseaux sociaux et sur notre site
internet je le disais en ouverture il ya
eu accélération cette semaine avec la
publication des décrets au lendemain de
la journée de mobilisation
comment doit-on le comprendre il avait
le cheviller vous avait été pris de
cours vous les syndicats sur la vitesse
de cette décision est ce que c'est parce
que vous n'étiez pas assez nombreux dans
la rue alors on était nombreux à faire
grève
plus de 50 % on connaît les divergences
de chiffres qui s'expliquent très
facilement cédé des approches techniques
on va pas perdre trop de temps là-dessus
mais on maintient qu on a été plus de
50% être en grève
effectivement dans la rue on a été un
petit peu déçue par les rassemblements
dans la rue devant les rectorats et les
manifestations
néanmoins les enseignants que je
représente les salles des professeurs
parce que moi je suis encore devant les
les élèves les enseignants que je
représente son vrai très mécontent de ce
qui s'est passé
son carré se sentent désavoué par leur
leur ministre et cela le prix la vitesse
de très très mal pris très très mal pris
ce qui va donc accélérer les actions qu
au courant du mois de juin vient de
changer de look elle favorable à la
réforme où vous avez été estimé que le
cheminement était normal et qu'il
fallait prendre des décisions oui tout à
fait faut assumer son projet politique
quand on en a dans un syndicat et cette
réforme est bonne pour les élèves donc
mais pas de raison d'appeler à la
contestation
il y a quand on dit pris de court il ya
eu débat depuis un petit moment
lier la le conseil supérieur d'éducation
s'est prononcée et c'est donc peut pas
dire ont été pris de court c'est un
échec cuisant pour les conservateurs qui
sont allés dans la rue qui ont voulu
mobiliser quand on annonce 70 % la
veille de la manifestation et que se
retrouve à 30 %
c'est malheureusement mais comme on
notera que la divergence de chiffres il
ya pas qu entre manifestants et
préserver ya aussi entre syndicats comme
comme d'ailleurs les échecs des
dernières manifestations sur les rythmes
scolaires etc
voilà ce n'est plus un mode qui
intéresse les enseignants et ils veulent
du changement
donc voilà c'est une réforme qui propose
du changement jean jacques rey y avait
aussi une politisation très forte
dossier on va dire que les représentants
de la droite ont aussi été pris de court
par la décision du gouvernement de
passer décret dès mercredi politisation
je sais pas en tout cas c'est un débat
qui intéresse tout le monde c'est vrai
qu'à chaque fois qu'on touche à l'école
au sens large du terme
la société se mobilise donc qu'il ya eu
effectivement des expressions politiques
qui ont été assumés particulier
d'information qu'est la mienne
moi ce que je note c'est que il ya à la
fois un empressement pour faire passer
la réforme prendre les décrets très très
vite mais ça a suivi finalement un temps
assez court on a traité les opposants
parlent les prix où on a qualifié les
intellectuels de pseudos intellectuels
ou parce qu'on se posait la ministre ont
été traités de racistes ou des
xénophobes un moment donné je pense que
c'est pas les bonnes conditions du débat
c'est vrai que ça n'avait pas à passer
devant le parlement
mais c'est avec intérêt avait déjà été
votée mais savait mais c'est vrai qu'un
débat devant le parlement ce qui est
toujours loisy le gouvernement ça aurait
quand même donner du poids à la démarche
est peut-être un peu plus de légitimité
parce qu'aujourd'hui elle en manque
cruellement
et le passage en force qui est assumé
non pas par la ministre mais par le
sommet de l'exécutif c'est le premier
ministre et le président à mon avis
c'est pas la bonne méthode pour arriver
à aplanir un certain nombre de
difficultés
il ya besoin de réformer le collège
qu'on est d'accord et sans doute pas
cette façon là sa femme écoutez moi je
suis content que france 3 bourgogne
organise ce type de débat parce que on
va sortir un petit peu des clichés des
caricatures
on entend parler depuis depuis quelques
quelques semaines va essayer on va
essayer en tout cas cette loi elle ne
vient pas ici comme un cheveu sur la
soupe est déçu de la loi pour la
refondation de l'école une loi qui veut
plus d'autonomie qui veut plus
d'interdisciplinarité qui veut plus
d'accompagnement personnalisé et
effectivement elle a été pensée elle
était lui beaucoup de consultations au
monsieur champdivers parler du conseil
supérieur de l'éducation
il faut quand même savoir que ce conseil
supérieur de l'éducation travail et
consulte depuis des mois depuis des mois
il est composé c'est important de le
rappeler aussi il est composé à la fois
deux syndicats il est composé
d'enseignants chercheurs et de
personnels de direction de personnels
administratifs mais aussi de parents
d'élèves de lycéens demande des
collectivités voilà donc c'est un
conseil super qui travaillent et quatre
ans chez le 10 avril dernier il a pris
une décision et une très large majorité
il a adopté cette réforme donc je crois
que c'est important de rappeler tout ça
ce cheminement parce qu'on a
l'impression que cette semaine il ya une
accélération en fait il n'y a pas
d'accélération et je crois qu'on pouvait
pas laisser le collège dans un tel état
vous voyez bien un petit peu les
enquêtes qui nous classe comme le
mauvais élève de la classe je parle de
l'enquêté pisa de l'ocde où on voit
qu'on est dégradée systématiquement en
français en mathématiques et surtout ce
que souligne cette enquête s'est combiné
en train de devenir le système éducatif
le plus inégalitaire des pays de sédhiou
et ça on ne pouvait pas rester sans rien
faire
je crois que ça paraît vraiment très
important de la chute avait envie de
répondre oui je voudrais réagir sur deux
choses parce qu'on se fait traiter de
conservateurs donc je voulais quand même
préciser une chose c'est qu'on est bien
conscient que quelque chose ne va pas au
collège aujourd'hui je perds c'est
justement vous ouvrez c'est la suite de
nos discussions au louvre au louvre
comme ça qu'est-ce qui va pas ou que la
personne j'ai terminé ce que vous en
personne ne nie cet état de fait mais
nous nous voulons une réforme est pas
cette réforme là on voulait le préciser
est par ailleurs les enquêtes
internationales pisa par exemple dont
vous venez de parler
il faut quand même voir que le nombre
d'heures en français et en maths n'ont
cessé de diminuer depuis la réforme haby
si on prend un élève qui en 1977 un
élève faisait du français du cp à la fin
de troisième
il avait 78 de français sur son cursus
est d'omaha fin si on prend leur
hebdomadaire et qu'on le cumul jusqu'à
la fin de troisième se faisait 60 18
heures aujourd'hui on en est à 53 eur
alors moi j'aime beaucoup il ya quand
même 80 % d'une classe d'âge qui va au
bac ce n'était pas le cas en 77
je me fais l'avocat du diable moi je
comprends pas on dit que l'école est
plus en plus mauvaises aujourd'hui 80%
d'une classe % d'une classe d'âge qui va
je tiens à son baccalauréat il est où
l'échec du collège là dedans c'est
plutôt un succès non je n'insisterai sur
ce qu'a dit monsieur guidel et les
écarts sont de plus en plus important
quand même vous avez les enquêtes comme
comme pisa qui montre que les meilleurs
élèves sont au niveau des élèves de la
finlande et les moins bons sont au
niveau du mexique et français des moins
bons sont au niveau du mexique s'était
passé quand même c'est énorme et il faut
du coup transformé les méthodes
d'apprentissage voilà c'est pas en
rajoutant des des heures des heures des
heures et en rajoutant du savoir
complètement il faut modifier les
méthodes d'apprentissage de nos élèves
et donc il faut passer à de
l'interdisciplinarité comme ça se fait
déjà aux primaires ou comme ça peut se
faire dans les lycées professionnels
voilà je le battrai à dire que parce
qu'on à 80 % d'une classe d'âge au
niveau du bac
on arrive à avoir des résultats c'est
faux parce que en réalité on sait très
bien ce qui s'est passé c'est on a fixé
un objectif quantitatif
or on doit travailler sur du qualitatif
80% à mener 4 1 % d'une classe d'âge
quand les savoirs fondamentaux ne sont
pas acquis dès l'école primaire
aujourd'hui c'est de 13 alors selon les
sexes les garçons 13% les filles 11% qui
sortent du cm2 sans savoir une maîtrise
suffisante des savoirs fondamentaux qui
leur permettront de continuer
correctement reconnaît juste pour qu'on
comprenne bien là sur le constat vous
vous êtes plutôt d'accord sur le fait
que le collège a besoin d'une réforme il
a besoin d'une réforme et c'est
passablement le collège qui a besoin de
réformes c'est l'ensemble de l'éducation
nationale il faut pas la limiter aux
collèges cent cinquante mille cent
cinquante mille des décrocheurs est ce
que c'est une réussite du système non et
aujourd'hui quand vous avez le bac en
poche vous avez une classe d'âge les
jeunes qui sont à 25 % de chômeurs a
livré ce qu'on sait faire des politiques
de droite et de gauche des dernières
aujourd'hui il ya un constat qui est que
le système éducatif ne produit pas ce
qu'on pourrait attendre de lui
c'est à dire une acquisition
transmission des savoirs suffisant on
parlera peut-être du fonds d'arrivée oui
mais il est celle qu'il est lié quand
même très étroitement c'est à dire la
réforme des programmes parce que on est
quand même au coeur de la question et à
partir de là on ne peut pas évidemment
considérer que notre système fonctionne
le cd a raison de pointer du doigt ces
dysfonctionnements mais je pense que la
réponse qui est à portée aujourd'hui par
le parlement n'est pas la bonne réponse
il s'agit pas de réformer pour être
moderne et c'est ça la grande illusion
du parti socialiste c'est de dire je
réforme donc je suis lauder donc vous
vous êtes les conservateurs etc c'est
trop réducteur on ne peut pas aller dans
ce débat là sinon on débattra pas du
faux ces packs certains de ses discours
comme quoi enfin j'espère qu'on
reviendra fait j'y reviendrai totalement
oublié oubliant de la droite en matière
d'éducation
mais enfin quand même juste justement
cette réforme s'inscrit dans la loi sur
la refondation est justement vous
parliez d'écoles primaires mais c'est la
pièce d'un puzzle et danseuses
il y à bien sur les rythmes scolaires la
priorité qui a été donnée aux primaires
la refonte des programmes là où les et
les enseignants peuvent s'exprimer
d'ailleurs sur ces programmes jusqu'au
jusqu'au 12 juin je crois et puis on a
également on remet de la formation
initiée en fin de la formation pour les
enseignants en formation qui était mise
à mal par la droite
qui était au pouvoir voilà donc je crois
qu'à un moment donné il faut remettre
les choses à leur place et recevoir des
leçons de politique éducative par la
droite
enfin excusez moi ça me fait doucement
rigoler soudain entre 2002 et 2012 on a
eu droit à quoi on est droit à 80 mille
suppressions de postes dans l'éducation
nationale 80 mille suppressions de
postes c'est quoi qui est des
suppressions de postes
ça fait moins d'infirmières scolaires -
de conseillère d'orientation psychologue
moins d'assistantes sociales - abs pour
s'occuper des personnes handicapées
voilà la réalité aujourd'hui et puis la
formation des enseignants qui étaient
mises à mal qui était quasiment
supprimés alors aujourd'hui vous savez
où on en est dans les établissements on
en est à recruter à pôle emploi
voilà voilà ça c'est la réalité c'est la
politique dont on subit les conséquences
donc il est temps de réformer et fait
loi pour la refondation d'école
effectivement elle va dans le bon sens
et longtemps elle a été entamée il ya
plusieurs années et depuis 2012 et y ait
une logique voilà c'est ça explique
qu'on doit expliquer c'est cette logique
là et alors on a fait à d'état je
voudrais quand même apporter une
précision parce que vous avez parlé du
conseil supérieur de l'éducation tout à
l'heure et je veux savoir que sur 97
personnes qui siègent au conseil
supérieur il y a vingt professeurs c'est
tout mais le résultat ça a compté une
voix pour 25
oui mais ce sont pas libres a fait signe
aux errements des parents d'élèves et g
data met sur les questions sur les vingt
professeurs 14 ans voté contre et 6 pour
je vais dans mon cas je vais provocateur
réseau national
est ce que justement ce que vous venez
de nous dire pose pas la question de ce
qu'est l'école aujourd'hui c'est à dire
est ce que l'école n'est que
majoritairement le fait des enseignants
est ce qu est ce que les parents
l'environnement le monde économique est
ce que tout le monde n'a pas son mot à
dire
ce n'est pas que majoritairement en tout
cas ce n'est pas que le fait d
enseignants bien entendu c'est quand
même beaucoup de plaisanciers
les acteurs jean avait bien compris que
je veux provoquer volontairement
quand on parle de lui demande économie
nous ça nous aurons pas par rapport au
collège ça nous chiffonne vous par
rapport à d'autres adhésions super rien
mais il est terrassé encore autre chose
regardons les lèvres alors jeunes
commandé par an pour la société où il
faut à chaque fois des enseignants on
est un syndicat des enseignants de la
maternelle au lycée nous on a nos pose
d'ailleurs aucun problème on n'est pas
séparée par corps et il faut un moment
donné se dire quel est l'intérêt pour
l'élève et pour la société en général
dans les bonnes vous voulez quelque
chose avant qu'on passe au coeur
finalement cette loi elle relève plutôt
du bon sens que d'idéologie c'est ça
dont on se rend compte quand on rentre
en profondeur dans la réforme est face à
une droite qui a cassé les systèmes
éducatifs je crois que là il ya une
vraie vision à long terme et je crois
qu'en période de crise c'est important
parce qu'on se rend compte que depuis
2002 1 l'école plutôt que de compenser
les effets de la crise a fait que les
accentuer et c'est ce qui explique ces
dix grosses différences dans les
enquêtes pisa sur les inégalités qui se
creusent donc je crois que c'est
vraiment l'esprit la réforme qui est
important c'est lutter contre ces
inégalités là et là il ya une vraie
logique raid dans alors on va justement
à propos des inégalités tout cas ça a
été dénoncé
si on rentre dans le corps dans le corps
de la réforme on va commencer par feu
dont on a le plus parlé peut-être à tort
d'ailleurs c'est ce qui concerne les
langues l'enseignement des langues
vivantes enseignement des langues mort
en gros pour faire simple pour ceux qui
n'ont pas suivi le dossier
on supprime ce qui était optionnelle
pour certains élèves c'est à dire le bi
langue anglais allemand les deux langues
dès la 6eme les sections européennes un
peu plus tard c'est à dire un peu plus
d'anglais par exemple et latin et on
instaure pour tout le monde de langue en
5e une initiation la culture antique
donc est-ce qu'on peut présenter ça
comme ça on enlève ou meilleurs élèves
pour redistribuer à tout le monde
gilles platret c'est votre vision des
choses ça va me permettre de répondre à
collègues socialistes parce qu'il nous
dit qu a pas d'idéologie dans cette
réforme il ne vit que donc la droite est
forcément mauvaise en matière
d'éducation parce que la gauche serait
la seule à pouvoir réussir des réformes
c'est un mythe quand même assez
extraordinaire que vous pensiez à gauche
que vous êtes les seuls à pouvoir vous
occupez d'éducation comme si non mais
j'ai comme si comme s'il est clé la
dégradation du système éducatif
elle n'est pas portée par un parti
politique vous avez été aussi aux
affaires à un moment donné donc arretez
de dire que tout est la faute de vos
adversaires
moi je prends la réforme des piolets et
j'essaye de l'analyser et j'analyse
aujourd'hui avec l'idéologie qui la
portent et c'est une idéologie anti
élites c'est très clair on considère que
les classes bilangues de 6e sont
réservées pour des élèves favorisés
au lieu de favoriser l'intégration
d'élèves venus de la mixité sociale au
sein de ces classes ont dit on les
supprime comme ça on a réglé le problème
et c'est une méthode pour le coup
complètement idéologique et il en va de
même d'ailleurs pour l'enseignement du
latin et du grec
certes le grec est a pris d'une manière
résiduelle 3% mais c'est tout de même
les racines d'une partie de notre langue
française
le latin aussi et qu'on ne vienne pas me
dire qu'on a préservé latin parce qu'en
réalité par le jeu de ceux raccrochage à
des activités périphériques qui sont
liées à l'eau monde antique en
particulier on va aboutir à une
dégradation de l'apprentissage du latin
donc on se coupe d'une partie des
racines de la langue française je pense
que cette vidéo logis à l'état pur
elle est à l'heure elle est à l'oeuvre
dans les programmes est à l'oeuvre sur
ses décisions et sur d'autres encore et
ça n'est pas acceptable donc c'est ça
que nous combattons en réalité pour en
arriver donc pour répondre sur sur le
thème des vies langue et du latin moi je
voudrais quand même rappeler que les
bilingues existe dans tous les collèges
d'éducation prioritaire donc ce n'est
pas forcément élitiste et le latin
également et il permet d'ailleurs de
préserver une certaine mixité sociale
dans ces établissements
je dois comprendre que ça dans la
réforme vous n'êtes pas forcément fin ça
vous plaît pas du tout on est bien
d'accord
le retrait des liens non ça nous plaît
pas du tout non non non alors les bi
langues
je rappelle quand même que les bilingues
ont été instaurés pour sauver la halle
aux sucres et en rugby mais l'âme après
l'instauration de la langue à l'école
primaire et de l'obligation de suite au
collège voilà qui vous à disparaître
quasiment la possibité verbalement alors
le problème c'est que à l'instauration
des bilans
les élever deux allemands ont disparu
dans les établissements alors on nous
dit on enlève les bi langues
on va mettre élevé 2 en cinquième ok
pourquoi pas mais est ce que on va
rouvrir toutes les sections d'allemands
lv2 qui ont été qui ont été fermés
depuis depuis 15 ans c'est ça c'est la
grande inquiétude est que des collègues
d'allemand par ailleurs le le latin il
ya encore 20 % des l'influent font les
20% dans les années 70 avait déjà 20 %
donc ça ça ne diminue pas donc c'est pas
c'est pas un critère d'excellence
épaisse année c'est encore moins un
critère d'excellence si dans les
établissements scolaires s'est fait
comme ça doit être fait c'est à dire les
élèves sont dispatchés dans plusieurs
classes et non pas dans une classe de
chant d'hiver est ce que m deux langues
vivantes dès la cinquième à des élèves
qui ont du mal ça va les aider
est-ce que tu as dur c'est pas pour ça
qu'on avait enlevé la lv2 en 5e il ya
quelques années comme lassé par les
bilans pour justement fait mais les deux
hommes concernés - moins d'élèves en
fait oui 15 oui c'est sûr qu'elle n'ait
15 à 20% alors d'une je voudrais redire
parce qu'on a entendu tout et n'importe
quoi toutes les vies langues ne sont pas
supprimés
certaines qui vont être maintenus pour
la continuité pédagogique aussi à
travers le cycle 3 donc voilà et on
instaure du coût humain élevé 2 pour
tous parce que le principe de la réforme
c'est on est obligé d'y venir c'est
c'est bien la justice et que tous les
élèves aient le même nombre d'heures
dans dans qu'il soit en sixième en
cinquième en 4e - troisième et on
supprime les options 1 et on l'a on
essaye de laisser la chance à tous mais
paradoxalement ce que les élèves condé
avec les collègues d'environ josiane ça
va les aider
oui mais la différence c'est que le même
nombre d'heures et en plus on dédouble
et ont fait de l'accompagnement
personnalisé ont fait on travaille
autrement avec de l'interdisciplinarité
en réponse à monsieur plâtre et le latin
grec doit pas être que dans les autres
pays
dans les enseignements pratiques
interdisciplinaire il sera ce il pourra
être dans les autres pays pour tous mais
il ya aussi un enseignement de
complément à hauteur de 5 heures un
enseignement de complément de latin
c'est justement là dessus que le se-unsa
est intervenue au moment dé du projet de
réforme
pour justement essayer de maintenir ses
heures pour pour certains qui voudraient
faire ce choix
donc est ce que vous estimez vraiment
qu'il est sérieux d'imposer une deuxième
langue dès la 5e pour tout le monde au
nom de l'égalitarisme qui vous anime
quand on a des élèves qui n'arrivent
déjà pas à maîtriser la langue française
et ses rudiments
est-ce que vous pensez que c'est l'élan
d'une deuxième langue dès la 5e c'est ça
la question de fond est ce que vous
pensez que l'objectif premier n'est pas
déjà d'assurer l'apprentissage du
français et des matières de base des
savoirs plutôt que d'en rajouter dès la
5e j'ai pas en rajoutant et du français
des maths de montréal et le plaisir vous
dites pour tous donc l'impression quand
c'est pour tous c'est nécessairement
très bien moi je pense qu'il faut au
contraire garder les cas particulier des
élèves et je pense que cette mesure
généralisée n'est pas bonne voilà je
vous le dis elle n'est pas bonne dès la
5e imposer une deuxième langue étrangère
dès la cinquième pour des élèves qui ont
des difficultés qui ne sont pas arrivés
par ailleurs dans leur langue maternelle
ça n'est pas une bonne chose et vous
pensez qu'avec des classes de 30 élèves
et en rajoutant des heures de français
de maths et en cumulant comme ça le
nombre d'heures on va résoudre les
150000 décrocheurs bleus moi j'ai hâte
en soit le fait de fast ou forcée sur
les apprentissages qui sont les
apprentissages de base n'est pas mauvais
après on sait bien que la réforme c'est
les élèves sont ni au collège il faut
pas les mettre dans une situation de
mal-être et ses meilleures liaisons avec
l'extraordinaire dans cette réforme pour
casser en fait les élèves qui veulent
travailler et par ni pour niveler par le
bas je suis désolé la philosophie même
si on en parlera un peu plus tard la
philosophie elle est bien là et c'est
celle ci qu'on combat stéphane guillou
attendait patiemment oui écoutez je
crois qu'il faut dire aussi dans cette
réforme il ya quand même choisi surpris
d'entendre les syndicats parlé ainsi il
ya quand même quatre mille postes créés
ring pour cette réforme du collège c'est
quand même important de les guider ces
derniers jours c'est important de le
souligner ensuite pour en revenir aux
mobiles enfin je crois qu'il ya un
moment donné il faut il faut être
sérieux aussi 1 les langues étrangères
on est quasiment le seul pays en europe
à introduire la deuxième guitare partout
ailleurs où ça se fait ça pose aucun
problème et c'est pas en concurrence
avec l'apprentissage de la langue
maternelle d'ailleurs les tous les
chercheurs en éducation sont d'accord là
dessus c'est à dire sur l'égalitarisme
jeu sam ou sur l'égalité
non mais à un moment donné cette
rengaine de l'égalitarisme tout ce qu'on
va mettre en place dans cette réforme et
qui va être accessible on va rentrer de
latin est effectivement monsieur
champdivers a raison pour le coup le
gouvernement était plutôt ouverts à la
discussion puisque du coup on garde une
option latin en cinquième une heure et
on 4e 3e 2e mais en plus on permet à
travers les hautes et inficon que le
niveau de latin seront beaucoup plus
faible que précédemment pour les élèves
pas du tout des faits réels mandela et
on vous le dit lui-même saupoudrer un
complément donc ce sera pas il n'aura
pas offert la légation obligatoirement
sommes actuellement à l'est comme un
événement chez les jolie gator à qui je
relance notre discussion
on a parlé des langues il faut quand
même qu'on parle aussi de ce qu'il ya
dans le coeur aussi de cette réforme si
on a beaucoup parlé des langues et
finalement pas forcément d'autres alors
il ya des programmes pour une histoire
qu'on fait beaucoup de bruit mais il ya
aussi quand même un point de
fonctionnement importants pour le
collège c'est à la fois
l'interdisciplinarité le fait de croiser
les enseignements et puis c'est
l'autonomie plus forte laisser au chef
d'établissement si j'ai bien compris
dites-nous sur ce point là c'est à dire
à terre d'ici dernier réalité autonomie
ce que vous pensez de la réforme des chu
et l'interdisciplinarité s'est croisé
des connaissances nous on n'est pas
forcément compte d'ailleurs on connaît
au collège ans on a eu les travaux
croiser les parcours diversifié les
idées d enfin on connaît bon sauf qu'il
n'ya jamais eu vraiment de bilan du fait
de tout ça mais on n'est pas forcément
contre le problème dans cette réforme
c'est que l'interdisciplinarité rogne
sur va prendre sur les horaires
disciplinaires
c'est précisément ça qui nous gêne parce
que les élèves en difficulté ils ont
besoin de savoir structurant de choses
qui les structurent et il faut il donc
on ne saurait être interdits sippley
narith et s'appuie sur les savoir s'il
n'ya pas va passer de savoir là et
l'interdisciplinarité
elle va pas forcément fonctionner et
vous avez vous même tout à l'heure c'est
nier le problème des décrocheurs est-ce
que l'interdisciplinarité
alors oui c'est un peu ça peut ben
justement oui mais s'ils ont pas les
savoirs de base pour maîtriser les
concepts
quand on met par exemple sur le papier
le développement durable en cinquième
écoutez moi
très bien mais le développement dira
c'est une notion qui très vaste très
complexe je croyais à l'intelligence des
enseignants quand même qu'ils vont se
traduire pour les élèves je sais pas
mais c'est des thématiques ça des deux
pays pour répondre vraiment c'est
justement ça le kiki qui va transformer
les choses vous les plb les profs de
lycée professionnel où les professeurs
des écoles qui sont déjà dans l'interdît
il rigole de voir ce spectacle et on
parle de quoi on parle de quatre heures
sur 26 heures que 20 peuvent avoir les
lève donc on n'est pas non plus dans une
révolution est dans une réforme qui
révolutionne tout est justement
l'interdisciplinarité pour avoir fait
plusieurs projets ce que cd pédagogie de
projet où on peut associer tous les
élèves
c'est ce qui fait réussir notamment les
moins bons et parce que ils ont un
intérêt commun toute la classe fait des
mois mais mener des projets danse par
exemple avec des élèves de tous niveaux
et bien dans ce projet là vous n'avez
pas du coup et plus de différence entre
entre les élèves et il arrive à un but
commun et donc ils réussissent et ils
travaillent les fondamentaux quand on
fait d'interdisciplinarité faut arrêter
de mettre les choses à côté
donc vous êtes en train de dire que vous
voulez garder toutes les heures et en
plus med c'est ce qui actuellement est
en plus mettre de l'interdisciplinarité
non changeons le modèle changeons de
modèles de l'interdisciplinarité ne
gomme pas les spécificités et les met en
valeur et je crois qu'il faut faire
aussi il faut parier aussi sur
l'intelligence et puis faire confiance
aux équipes pédagogiques
il ya des conseils pédagogiques oui mais
je suis désolé mais à un moment donné il
ya des conseils pédagogiques et les
enseignants qui se trouve dans un lycée
dans un collège connaissent bien la
spécificité de leurs aînées elles sont
capables d'adapter cep des ics et voilà
donc un moment donné je crois qu'il faut
faire comprendre pu faire confiance
aussi aux chefs d'établissement voilà
donc cédé travail d'équipé aussi des
chefs d'établissement sont des gens qui
passent des concours qui sont quand même
apte à diriger un établissement les
ailes et les enseignants c'est bien pour
ça que j'ai mais c'est bien pour ça
qu'il faut leur faire confiance
c'est il faut leur faire confiance et
j'entends beaucoup d' immobilisme dans
votre discours quand qantas et alors que
cette réforme j'ai l'impression qu'on
est plutôt tournée vers l'avenir
parce que je n'entends pas tellement de
propositions finalement face j'entends
pas de progrès
vous proposez l'immobilisme
changez rien monsieur platret lui
enlever des postes avoir une vision
comptable au niveau désirs pour des
réalités
mais vous prenez que vous allez c'est
pas écrire des choses que l'on n'est pas
vraiment atypique chez vous mais enfin
tout de même n'avait pas trop au lieu de
répondre sur ce coup là alors évidemment
donc un moment donné face à face à cette
logique comptable je crois qu'on doit
avoir une vision à plus long terme du
système éducatif et cette loi pour la
refondation de l'école s'inscrit dans
cette vision à plus long terme je crois
qu'il ya un vrai projet derrière et
encore une fois c'est lutter contre les
inégalités on ne peut pas rester sans
rien alors justement puisque vous venez
prononcé la phrase est du coup j'ai
loupé la trêve vous pouvez rebondir sur
ce que je vais dire vous vous dites
lutter contre les inégalités
on a entendu le premier ministre et la
ministre de l'éducation qu'on tapait
fort et là on aborde un peu on va le
faire rapidement avant l'avant midi et
on continuera après l'esprit de cette
réforme en disant que globalement les
opposants à la réforme défendent est
d'abord leurs privilèges
le mot a été prononcé par par manuel
valls
est ce que ça veut dire que ceux qui ont
réussi ont des enfants qui réussissent
et ne veulent pas que ça change est ce
qu'on doit le comprendre comme ça en
tout cas gilles platret aussi c'est une
vue de l'esprit
bon moi pour revenir sur le sur le fond
même de la réforme est peut-être sur
l'aspect interdisciplinaire il ya juste
une petite phrase que je veux citer
parce que elle résume complètement
l'esprit cette réforme on veut permettre
de créer avec les enseignements
pratiques interdisciplinaire les
fameuses et pis un climat je cite de
confiance dans lequel on peut
questionner sans crainte et où disparaît
la peur excessive de mal faire donc il
faut bien vous dire une chose c'est que
la peur excessive de mal faire elle est
consubstantiel à toute action
quand on commence à dire il ya des
élèves qui ont la peur de mal faire donc
il faut que tout le monde soit sur des
allées des allégements parce que vous
avez entièrement raison les savoirs
fondamentaux seront nécessairement renié
par la mise en place de ces
enseignements qui sont forcément pris
sur un temps qui était consacrée par
ailleurs aux enseignements fondamentaux
et plus que les itinéraires de
découverte par exemple qui existent
aujourd'hui ça c'est un fait avéré
donc on est au coeur même d'une réforme
qui je le redis nivelle par le bas qui
dénonce c'est normal s'il ya une logique
qui dénonce ceux qui réussissent et qui
décide de mettre tout le monde sur un
niveau plus bas comme ça tout le monde
est à égalité
c'est ce que j'appelle l'égalitarisme
c'est pas l'égalité sociale c'est pas
l'égalité des chances c'est simplement à
un moment donné prendre le contre-pied
d'abus n'est que
d'un collège qui donne sa chance à tout
le monde qu'ils accompagnent ceux qui
ont des difficultés particulières
on n'a jamais dit le contraire bien
évidemment mais qui arrête de casser
ceux qui ont des savoirs à faire valoir
et qui veulent se réaliser aussi par ça
et c'est exactement ce que vous êtes en
train de faire un moment donné vous
parler des programmes en fait c'est bien
pour ça que parallèlement à cette
réforme en est mis en place et le
conseil supérieur des programmes est
chargé de ça et on consulte l'ensemble
des enseignants c'est aussi ça dialoguer
durs sont en grande partie en désaccord
avec ce que la mouture qui était
approuvé aujourd'hui c'est bien se
décider la date du 12 juin
bien sûr sincèrement d'ici là je suis
garé à une réforme fondamentale de ce
qui nous avait été proposé parce que
c'est complètement aberrant mais ce
gouvernement gauche elle même l'a
dénoncé mesa gouvernement monsieur
monsieur platret est ouvert au dialogue
j'en veux j'en veux pour preuve ils leur
montrent régulièrement en veut pour
preuve j'en veux pour preuve la réforme
des collèges sont fort si on ouvert au
dialogue
c'est un peu contradictoire oui oui
c'est bien choses différentes la
ministre dit la porte de mon bureau est
ouverte et valse dit ben moi je prends
le décret immédiatement donc
effectivement c'est ce qu'on appelle une
ouverture dialogue comme ses balises est
libre ce n'est pas comme je lé démontrer
tout à l'heure il ya une longue
concertation et vous pouvez pas dire que
c'est un passage en force
pour en venir à ce monsieur me laisse
ceux qui manifestent leur mécontentement
je crois pas qu'il faille stigmatiser je
crois qu'on a besoin aussi de dialoguer
et ce gouvernement a toujours été prêt
et à dialoguer il faut continuer à
dialoguer le décret maintenant est passé
on passe à l'étape suivante la loi a
déjà été votée ou les répéteurs on n'a
pas à revenir à l'assemblée nationale ça
ça rime à rien donc on est dans une
logique il faut que tout soit prêt pour
la rentrée 2016 parce que ça aussi c'est
l'urgence et je vous dis on poursuit ce
débat bien sûr sur l'esprit de cette
réforme parce qu'on a juste aborder ça
juste après les infos de midi on se
retrouve dans une poignée de minutes et
on passe la parole à l'équipe du flash
de la mi journée a tout de suite